So the last three weeks,
then we've been going through some of the major developments in terms of
political and religious change in the course of the 16th century.
And for the next three weeks we'll be looking at other aspects of,
of what was going on,
uh,
in the reign of Elizabeth and under the early Stuart's dealing with a number of
themes that run across from about 1562,
1640,
and then we'll returned to the political narrative.
So I'm going to look at things like witchcraft and crime and popular protest and
education and the growth of literacy.
Um,
but first of all,
this week,
in order to understand all of these developments and create the context of
change,
we need to know what was going on in economy and society,
both of which were changing in their structure,
quite significant in these two generations at the turn of the 16th and 17th
centuries.
And today I'll focus on the economic developments.
Um,
so a bit of economic history,
economic history is rarely immensely popular.
Um,
but it does matter.
Uh,
it's absolutely basic.
Um,
it's perhaps an unfamiliar kind of history.
It's mostly done in economics departments.
Um,
but what I've tried to do basically is to give you a clear overview of what we
know about what seems to have been happening in this period and your handout.
We'll provide you with some statistics,
uh,
to chart the overall developments and illustrate some of the details.
Okay.
So by the 1560s already,
as you know,
population growth and price inflation had impacted to some degree upon
established patterns of social relationships,
especially on the land between landlords and tenants.
In this situation,
there was need for sustained economic expansion if a growing population was to
be maintained.
And in particular if the younger generation were to be able to find employment
to enjoy living standards comparable to those of their parents and such
expansion needed to be considerable if it was to keep pace with continued
population rise.
If you look at your handout table number one there we have the best figures
available for population showing that by the beginning of Elizabeth's reign in
1561 or two already reached about 3 million by 60,
you know,
wanted to topped 4,000,016 41 the population had risen to just over 5 million.
And in fact the population in England seems to have been rising faster and for
rather longer than was generally the case in Europe at the time between the
1520s and the 1640s,
the population of England and Wales roughly doubled.
Whereas in most European countries which have a continental European countries
which have been studied,
uh,
the rise was something like 50%.
Um,
that suggests that whatever the population rise in England had in common with
what was going on elsewhere in Europe,
perhaps in terms of its origins,
it was nonetheless being sustained rather long,
longer perhaps because of factors peculiar to the English situation.
That seems to have been a capacity to absorb increased numbers of people to a
somewhat greater extent than in much of continental Europe.
And that this could happen at all is of course an indication that some kind of
economic expansion was probably going on.
And so the question arises and has been extensively investigated,
uh,
as to what were the areas of economic expansion in this period?
Well,
in a predominantly rural society,
of course we need to begin with agriculture.
And if you look at a table two on your handout to a,
there's an index there of agricultural output.
It's the best estimate currently available,
calculated by the agricultural historian Mark Overton.
And it suggests that grain output rose by about 38% in England between and 50
and 1600 and by a further 26% between 1,616 50 over the entire period,
something like a 75% increase in grain output.
Well,
how do they achieve that?
One thing they did was to extend the cultivated area.
In fact,
very little land was not used at all.
So really this was largely a matter of changing the use of the land so as to
increase the intensity of its use.
They did that in many ways.
One way was by clearing woodlands and bringing him the wood,
the woodland into Arabelle production.
I'm a good deal of that.
Went on in the heavily wooded areas of the West Midlands here and elsewhere.
Piece meal.
Another thing they did was to drain a waterlogged land and to reclaim it for
agriculture.
It was a good deal of that going on piecemeal around the country.
Uh,
down here in eastern England,
for example,
a lot of salt marsh along the coast was brought in permanently.
They built dikes so it wouldn't flood,
uh,
and drained it,
much in the manner that was practiced in the Netherlands of course.
Uh,
and brought that land into permanent pasture use.
A lot of wasteland was plowed up and brought into cultivation.
There was a lot of piecemeal change of that kind wherever wasteland was
available.
But there are also some very large projects of that kind,
which was sponsored and overseen by the Royal Privy Council.
Uh,
in the west of England.
A lot of forested land was Disa,
forested by the crown.
That is,
it's a,
it's a status as far as land was,
was canceled.
A woodlands were cleared.
Land was brought into cultivation all over the west.
Um,
another major scheme was in the Fed lands of East Anglia,
the fens where from the 16,
20 onwards gradually drained and that land was brought into cultivation.
Dutch engineers were brought in because of the expertise in draining land,
building dikes,
drainage channels and so forth.
It's because of that drainage which took place in the 17th century.
And if we drive through that area,
you find the roads are higher than the surrounding land.
Well,
much change then have this kind of going on.
And this tended to recast the balance between Arabelle and pastoral production
in the kingdom as a whole.
It also furthered increased specialization in accordance with the best use of
the land in the forest of Arden,
for example,
in Warwickshire an area which was previously largely an area of grazing in
forest clearances,
much of the forest was cleared and the land went over from meat production to
Arabelle and dairying.
Um,
amongst the arable crops,
they began growing more barley as well as wheat to diversify the product.
They generally increased the food base of the area.
They were producing milk and cheese and grain as well as meet and you've got
other areas where there's even more diversification.
I'm down in Kent to the southeast of London.
Northern can't became an area specializing in producing wheat for the bakers of
London.
Other areas of the county specialized in,
in fattening cattle,
which were driven down from the north fattened up and then went to butchers in
London.
There were areas specializing in hop production as they still are for the
brewers of London areas specializing in market gardening for the city,
proximity to the vast food market of London of course encouraged specialization
of that kind
and such specialization in various parts of the kingdom.
Intern encouraged intensification of cultivation
sometimes that was by introducing technical changes in agricultural production.
There was a lot of attention paid to better forms of maneuvering the land.
I'm not just using animal muck but also spreading Lyme on the fields or modeling
the fields,
uh,
model as a kind of chalky clay.
They would dig it up and spread it on the fields and then plow it in.
Um,
techniques of that kind had the effect of reducing the acidity of the soil and
they encouraged nitrogen mineralization,
which encouraged the fertility of the soil.
They didn't know the chemistry of what was happening,
but they knew that it worked and techniques of just kind,
we're quite widely practiced.
There were also technical changes in the form of changing rotations in the use
of land between having it down to grass or plowing it up for arable crops in
particular and innovation,
which was known as convertible husbandry or up and down husbandry.
It was often called previously the practice had been in the great open fields
around villages to leave one of them follow each year.
It would be rested for a single year and then brought back into production.
Convertible husbandry was a much more efficient form of rotation.
You would leave the grass,
the land down to grasp for quite a long time,
10 years,
12 years perhaps.
Then plow it up for just two or three years and then put it down to grass again.
The effect of this change in rotation was that the land was we got,
it's hard to restored better.
You've got greatly improved serial yields when it was plowed up for Arabelle,
but at the same time you had more of your acreage down to grass at any one time
so you could keep more animals so they could increase both their output of grain
and the density of the livestock,
which they raised this practice up and down or convertible husbandry had long
been known in some areas,
but it gradually spread as a particularly efficient practice.
Uh,
and it spreads all over lowland England between about the 1580s and the 1650s.
And finally change of all these kinds could be facilitated by enclosing the land
into individually managed farms.
As you know,
in the 16th century,
that had been great hostility to end closure for pasture,
which took land out of Arab oil production in the late 16th century,
partly because of this hostility to enclosure the enclosure movement slackened.
But at the turn of the 17th century,
it began to pick up again,
uh,
in the central England county of Leicestershire in the what people refer to as
the Midland plain of central England.
For example,
about a third of the county had already been enclosed by 1550 in the second half
of the 16th century,
only 5% more was in close the movement slackened.
But in the early 17th century,
it picked up again and 40% more of the county was in closed.
Similar figures have been produced for other areas,
particularly in the Midlands,
well this second of and closure of dividing up the fields and common into
smaller fields individually managed.
It was different in two respects from the earlier and closure movement.
First of all,
it was now not so much and closure for conversion to pasture,
especially conversion to sheep ranching.
Now it tended to be enclosure for the practice of improved Arabelle husbandry or
convertible husbandry.
When the forest of the West were cleared and the fence of the east were drained,
the land brought into production tended to be divided up into individual fields
and then let out to local farmers where they practice convertible husbandry and
they're in closed farms.
Secondly,
this differed because it was not a thing which was just pushed through
unilaterally by the local gentry who wanted to create sheep ranchers in the
early 16th century.
Now,
it was a movement which tended to proceed by agreement agreements,
which will be struck between local gentlemen and the principal,
local farmers,
their biggest tenants in the main,
and so you find all over the kingdom,
local communities coming to agreements of this kind to enclose the common fields
or the common pastures to take just one example is a village up in the West
Midlands called highly,
which has been much studied and it has excellent records and it's highly,
for example,
it was in the 1610s and the 1620s that the open fields of the parish will
gradually and close little by little by agreement,
and then they rounded the whole thing off by dividing up and portioning out the
woodlands and common pasture of the manner.
The whole idea of this was to create consolidated farms,
which would be under the individual management of a particular farmer that gave
those farmers freedom of movement in managing and adapting their husbandry
practice as they saw fit.
Intensification of methods was not impossible in the old open fields,
but it was much easier on farms under individual management.
And in consequence,
the old commonary managed customary system of agriculture gradually weakened it.
We can get hold on.
Agricultural Organization generally survived in some areas,
but in many parts of the country it was gradually disappearing and in some it
was almost wholly extinguished.
Right?
Overall various combinations of changes of this kind appear to have boosted
agricultural output considerably,
even boosting the yields per acre,
the productivity of the land,
um,
the study which is represented by the figures on to table to be on your handout
of land productivity in a number of counties,
a study based farmers inventories the crops that are recorded in their
inventories and also on some surviving account books.
This suggests that in these counties serially yields numbers of bushels per acre
rose by about 15% in the late 16th century and by another 4% in the early 17th
century.
Okay.
Well,
gradual change of this kind in agriculture implies that there existed a larger
market for agricultural produce and in some ways a more distant market for
agricultural produce that farmers we're trying to serve.
And those markets were found,
as you would imagine above all in the towns and in those areas of the country
side,
which had large populations,
um,
which we're engaged in activities other than agriculture,
industrial areas of the countryside.
This was a period of very marked urbanization,
very significant urban growth.
Some of the figures are there on table three on your handout for a number of
cities in Worcester,
for example,
the population rose between 1550 and 60 and 50 from just over 4,002 roughly
8,000 in Norridge,
the population of the city rose from about 10,000 to over 30,000
and above all,
there was a massive population growth in the city of London.
The figures are there for you.
1550 London was already about 70,000 by 1600 200,000 by 1650 400,000 and still
growing
by 1600 London already contained 5% of the national population by 1650 London
contained just over 9% of the national population and we're still growing and
today it's about 10% because it almost reached that proportion in the mid 17th
century.
So very significant urban growth,
all of that involved within particular cities,
the taking up a vacant space within their walls for building the subdivision of
existing housing and the growth of suburbs outside the old city walls in London
for example,
by the 1580s there were complaints by the local authorities of what they called
pestering of houses with diverse families or multiple occupation or again,
multitudes of people.
These are quotations multitudes of people brought to inhabit in small rooms and
heaped up together and in a sought almost smothered,
said one report overcrowding congestion.
In addition in the parish is outside the city walls.
There was significant suburban growth.
The parishes of east London to the east of the Tower of London.
The modern east stand in the 1570s contained about 7,000 people already.
There's already a significant population in these parishes just outside the old
city walls.
By the 1630s,
there were 50,000 people in the East London suburbs,
or if we turn to western London,
um,
the parish of Saint Martin in the fields,
which was literally in the fields in the mid 16th century,
had a population of about 600.
When Elizabeth came to the throne by the 1630s,
saint Martins had a population of 18,000 to this single London.
Suburban parish contained more people than most of the cities in other parts of
the kingdom.
The Church of Saint Martin's in the fields is the one that stands beside
Trafalgar Square today,
right in the heart of the city.
Well,
this formidable urban growth occurred despite alarming levels of urban mortality
in the overcrowded,
increasingly insanitary towns,
they didn't have adequate water supply.
They didn't have adequate sanitation measures.
Background mortality,
ordinary everyday mortality from infectious disease in the towns was very bad
followers.
And in the countryside,
even within the cities,
it could vary quite significantly.
For example,
in the late 16th century,
average life expectation at birth in the wealthier districts of London was 30 to
35 average life expectation of birth in the poorer parishes of the east end was
only 20 to 25.
The towns were also prone,
of course,
to catastrophic crisis mortality in the form of epidemics,
particularly epidemics of bubonic plague norritch.
So five major epidemics of plague between 1579 and 1640 London also.
So five in the same period and most other major cities witnessed a number.
These are brakes,
could kill 10 to 15% of the population or even worse.
Um,
in York in 1,604,
which was a really bad year when the plague spread from city to city across the
kingdom in York in that year,
roughly 30% of the population died in new castle up here in the northeast in
1636 an estimated 47% of the population died between May and October of that
year.
These were absolutely devastating events and they were at their worst in the
poorer,
overcrowded,
dirtier areas of the cities.
It's been said by Paul.
Slack has written a wonderful book about the impact of the plague,
that there was a distinct urban topography of the plague.
The disease was no respecter of persons,
but it raged at its worse under certain social conditions
and yet despite these appalling catastrophes,
the town's continued to grow London above all,
one of the earliest demographers,
a man named John Grant,
who published a study based upon the mortality figures for London,
which were regularly collected by the city authorities to keep an eye on the
epidemic disease situation.
He studied them for the first time.
He,
he,
he made various projections on the base of those fingers.
He was a great pioneer of the use of statistical information.
He came to the conclusion,
I'm quoting him,
let the mortality be what it will.
This city repairs itself.
Within two years,
the loss of inhabitants could be rapidly replaced and the evidence is that this
was so,
and of course the loss was replaced primarily by continued migration to the
towns.
It's been calculated that in order to replace the numbers who died under these
dreadful mortality conditions and to continue to grow in the way that it did,
London needed an average of 6,000 new people a year coming into the city to
replace his losses and grow.
And the evidence is that they came,
some of them came as what one demographer describes as betterment migrants,
people who came to the city in fairly confident expectation of better
opportunities.
They might come in as apprentices to be apprentice to a particular trade,
their apprenticeship,
having been arranged by members of their family.
They might be people who came in with a known place to fill very often,
for example,
they might have relatives already in the city who would encourage their
migration to join them.
Uh,
a very interesting study by Vivian Brodsky of single women marrying for the
first time in London,
uh,
and taking out licenses to marry,
which give us some details of their circumstances.
She finds interestingly that two fifths of these single women marrying in London
had kin in the city with whom they were living at the time that they married.
So they'd come in from the countryside,
they were living with family members already in the city,
and then they established themselves and,
and married.
Then
other people came not as betterment with good prospects of that kind,
but as what have been described as subsistence migrants,
people looking for any opportunity to find work and hoping that the city would
provide it.
And clearly it did,
perhaps not the opportunities that people hoped for the streets of London.
We're certainly not paved with gold,
but opportunities of a kind to make a living of some kind.
The quickening urban economies of other cities also did the same.
Um,
in culture stir and in Norridge for example,
the cloth industry was expanding,
uh,
particularly with the help of refugees from the Netherlands,
from the religious wars of the Netherlands who came and were placed in those
cities by Elizabeth's government,
uh,
and who are welcomed because they introduced certain advanced cloth making
techniques which helped to improve the local cross industry and assist its
expansion
in London.
Above all,
you get a spectacular diversification of manufacturing activity in east London.
Along the river.
There were shipyards.
They will also businesses producing all sorts of other goods ancillary to the
shipping industry,
rope making,
sail making,
Cooper's making barrels,
um,
people making pulleys pulley makers for the,
the ropes that held,
you know,
for the rigging of the ships.
Um,
in London you also find tech styles,
especially luxury textiles,
a massive brewing industry,
metal trades,
sugar refining,
starch making,
soap making,
glass making and so on,
could go on.
And then of course there was all the activity around the wharves and river in
what was England's greatest trading city.
So urban economies were expanding the numbers of apprentices being taken on with
growing the level of activity was growing,
the activities themselves were proliferating,
but manufacturing and other industries also extended well beyond the cities.
Manufacturing of some products had long been established in rural villages under
the putting out system.
And this period also witnessed considerable growth in activities of this kind.
It rarely involved really significant technological change of the kind that we
associate with the industrial revolution and the birth of the factory system.
But what it often saw was the adoption or the imitation of the best practices
known at the time and the diversification of the products which were being
produced.
And there was also something of a spread in the geographical location of various
kinds of activity.
As you know,
the premia traditional industry was the production of woolen broadcloth.
Most of it exported to the Netherlands where traditionally it was finished and
then passed onto markets across Europe.
This traditional industry had had something of a crisis of overproduction in the
1550s and thereafter found that its markets were somewhat declining.
It's overseas markets are somewhat declining and it faced a pretty stiff
competition from the Dutch.
But the textile industry has continued to expand.
Nonetheless,
the most dynamic areas of tech styles,
we're not the old broad cloth industry,
but the production of what they called the new draperies,
the new draperies,
these were lighter,
fully finished,
more colorful clots.
Um,
rather than like modern suit cloth.
If,
if old fashion,
if the old broad clots were rather like a heavy blanket,
uh,
then if you imagine modern modern suiting cloths,
that's what the new draperies were like Wooster's of various kinds.
They had lovely names for them and they are always inventing fancy names for
these new clots bays and ses and perpetual armors and Kelly Mancos.
All of these were different forms of Worcester cloth.
The new draperies were centered in the towns of East Anglia where they had been
with their establishment had been greatly assisted by the influx of skilled
refugees from the Netherlands.
They brought their expertise and they helped to revive and transform the clot
industries of those areas,
especially around knowledge and culture stuff,
but the new draperies weren't not the whole story of textile diversification up
in Lancashire around the town of Manchester,
which at this time is not a great city,
but a small market town.
There was the growth in the late 16th and early 17th centuries of the
manufacturer of so called fusty Ian's first.
Ian's involved a mixture of cotton and linen and the production of this clot.
It was cheap,
coarse cloth for the home market cloth for the poor was centered around
Manchester.
It's the distant ancestor of what was later to be the great cotton industry of
the city of Manchester.
Another thing that was spreading in many rural areas was stuck in knitting.
The wives of farmers and agricultural laborers were often involved in knitting,
high quality stockings.
Many people knitted stockings for themselves,
but there was a market for high quality stockings supplied by people working in
that way.
The stocking industry spread all over Norfolk spread across the Midlands into
Nottinghamshire area,
which is actually still to this day,
a set date for the manufacturer of stockings and the underwear marks and
Spencer's gets a lot of stuff from Nottingham Shit.
Um,
and so on.
one could talk about silks,
luxury textiles,
silks were introduced by French Protestant refugees from southern France and
silk production became established principally in eastern London and also in the
town of Canterbury,
in Kent.
So a lot of diversification,
not only in woolen textiles but in some new developments like silk.
And this was part of a larger diversification of manufacturing in town and
country.
A lot of the new manual,
the altogether new manufacturers which were introduced were really forms of
import substitution and courage by the royal government so that things could be
produced at home rather than imported.
Traditionally,
a great deal of miscellaneous manufactured goods actually were imported
principally from the Netherlands or north Germany
under Elizabeth.
The Privy Council was very responsive indeed to anyone with good ideas for
introducing these things into England.
They would often encourage them by granting them a patent,
which would give them the monopoly of producing a certain item for a stated
period of years after which it would be open to anyone who wished to participate
in the industry once it was established.
It's the origins of the patent system.
Of course.
Well,
numerous Peyton's were granted,
um,
to take some examples,
which may seem almost silly,
but they mattered.
Uh,
pins,
well it doesn't usually think of pins when one thinks of some major economic
expansion.
But in 1597,
England imported 40,000 pounds worth of pins from the Netherlands.
That's a lot of pins and a lot of money.
Um,
in the first decade of the 17th century pin manufacturing was established and
the picking in the suburbs of London,
they mostly employ children making the pins.
By the 1630s,
uh,
the patent had expired and it spread beyond London became particularly
established in villages in the west of England,
in the Gloucestershire area.
From about this time onward,
most English pins were produced at home.
And so one could go on.
Glass was nearly always important before the 1580s Peyton's.
But then granted for introducing glass manufacturer particular to particularly
to the counties of Kent and Sussex,
and then it spread to some other places.
They were glass glassworks around Newcastle very soon,
um,
by the 1620s,
nearly old glass bottles used in England were being produced at home instead of
imported and so on.
Well,
industries of this kind would generally somewhat decentralized in their
organization.
They were organized on the putting out system.
They didn't involve a great deal in the way of investment in fixed capital,
in the form of industrial plant machinery and so forth.
Principally,
they needed the capital,
uh,
to buy raw materials to pay workers who are working in their own cottages or
workshops to market the finished goods.
It was all done on the putting out system but there were a number of other
industries which were also beginning to bring a rather different face to
industrial activity.
Iron for example,
iron manufacturing really got going in the mid 16th century when the technique
of using blast furnaces was introduced into England from Germany.
It was greatly encouraged by Elizabeth's Privy Council because they wanted iron
production domestically for the production of munitions.
By the 1570s there were over 50 blast furnaces operating in the forests of the
area known as the wheels down here towards the south coast,
the forested area with fast running streams which was suitable for driving some
of the machinery involved in the early 17th century.
The industry in the wheeled a had stabilized,
even declined a little,
but there was a great deal of relocation to south Wales largely because that
area offered a combination of iron ore for us to provide the timber to produce
charcoal for the blast furnaces and also fast running streams to drive the
machinery which was used in slitting mills in iron production machinery driven
by water wheels.
All of this is a very interesting to go into in detail to see the technology
they use,
but I'll spare you that.
Um,
but it can be followed up if these things interest you.
Buy
by the 1580s,
the levels of iron production of the 1550s had increased three fold by the 1640s
England was producing 2120 4,000 tons of pig iron a year.
Those were the signs of things to come in the iron industry,
which continued to grow,
but a lot of iron was still imported from Scandinavia in particular from Sweden
especially to serve a growing industry,
producing metal wares.
And that was centered in the West Midlands around the town of Birmingham.
Metalware production had taken place there for many years in deed centuries but
was greatly increasing.
They produce their many metal products used in agriculture and in the building
industries and the shipping,
nails and blocks and sides and buckles,
latches for doors,
bits and stirrups for horses and so forth.
All of this was organized by iron masters who lived in emerging towns like
Birmingham,
Warsaw and star bridge.
And they did it partly by employing independent master to produce specialized
goods for them.
And also by putting out work,
putting out raw materials for the simpler items like nail making,
two cottages who work part time
and so on can go on.
Led production was also expanding.
Some of the figures are there,
uh,
in table four 1560 is only about 600 tons of lead produced per annum.
By the 1630s,
well over 12,000 led production was centered in the hills of Darbyshire and in
parts of Somerset where led deposits,
where to be found.
And finally,
perhaps most spectacular of all in the introduction of these new,
heavier industries was the growth of the coal industry.
The coal industry centered around new castle on the river.
Tyne grew spectacularly under Elizabeth and the early Stuart's in response above
all to the demands for fuel exerted by London and other growing cities.
In the 50 [inaudible] Newcastle exported to London through the coastal trade,
50,000 tons of coal a year.
By the 1640s it was exporting 300,000 tons of coal per year.
In addition to which by 1640 another 200,000 tons were being exported to other
English cities.
The coal industry could not have grown as it did without the demand being
exerted by these growing urban centers.
Those urban centers could not have grown as they did without the fuel,
the cheap fuel,
which was coming from the minds of the north by 1650 the northeast alone,
and they were coal fields in some other areas too,
but the northeast alone was producing half a million tons of coal per annum.
Quite extraordinary output.
Just to give you a sense of what that might mean.
A recent historian of these developments has calculated that a ton of coal
yields roughly the same heat energy as the charcoal,
which could be produced by harvesting timber on an acre of land.
Okay.
So same heat heat energy as the timber from an acre of land.
So if you're producing half a million tons of coal per annum,
you have in effect created half a million acres of land as it were in terms of
your,
the capacity you would need in order to produce that amount of heat energy.
And that he tended,
she was used not only for domestic heating,
but for any industrial process which required heat.
They couldn't use it for smelting iron,
but um,
they could use it for many,
many industrial processes.
So that clear did you get them the point?
Um,
it's an interesting way of,
of,
of representing the difference that that kind of industrial development could
make.
Okay.
Well,
much of this built on existing foundations,
but the sheer scale of expansion began to give a very distinct regional
geography to the English economy.
They were distinctive areas of agricultural specialization emerging and there
were also those areas which were rendered distinctive by their involvement in
industrial activity.
One traveler traveling through the West Midlands near Birmingham in the 1640s
described it as being like one continued village,
large village after large village,
heavily involved in iron production.
Um,
the Star valley area stretching up from culture to where the new draperies we're
well established.
It was described as with a continuing of consisting of a constellation of
villages in which a small number of clothing is set on work,
a great company of poor people
or there again there's the extraordinary moonscape which was emerging around
around the new castle coalfield area in which there were many,
many individual pits working down to depths of two or 300 feet and then they
couldn't really go any deeper because of drainage problems.
So they would simply open a new pit,
creating a kind of moonscape across that whole area.
This kind of regional differentiation enhanced the redistribution of the
population as people seeking work moved to places which had the capacity to
provide them with some kind of employment.
Be It in agriculture of particular kinds or in industry.
I've already touched on the migration to the towns.
There was also migration to certain rural areas which were becoming very densely
populated,
especially the manufacturing districts and those Dan densely populated areas of
course exerted demand in their turn for the agricultural products of a more
specialized agriculture.
Something of the redistribution of population which was going on is summarized
in section five of your handout.
There are some figures calculated by the demography ea Wrigley showing that
between 1520 and 1670 the rural agricultural population,
those directly employed in agriculture was significantly reduced.
The urban population living in towns of over 5,000 rose from about 5.5% to over
13% and the rural nonagricultural population rose from about 18% to something
like 26% that's the people living in small towns or working in rural industry.
Okay.
All of this was of course linked together by internal trade.
The established arteries of internal trade grew and their significance road
traffic,
increased traffic around the coast and on the rivers.
A very good way of moving bulky goods greatly increased networks of internal
trade were elaborated and tightened.
If that had not happened,
then none of these developments would have been possible.
The emerging picture is one of an elaborating web of commercial interconnection,
pulling the various regional economies together even more tightly than had
previously been the case and this intensification of commercial activity
involved new commercial practices and one of the best indicators of the sheer
extent of what was going on is actually provided by the evidence of the law
courts.
A great deal of the litigation which took place in England's law courts
concerned broken contracts,
disagreements over debts or the meeting of our contractual obligations.
There was an absolutely massive rise in the amount of such business within the
courts.
If you look at section six of your handout,
you'll see that in 1560 just over 5,000 cases of this kind were heard by the
central courts in London.
By 1640 it was almost 29,000 cases being heard a year,
and this is just the tip of the iceberg.
These are the deals that went wrong and resulted in someone suing someone else.
One can only imagine the massive amount of commercial activity which was going
on,
whereas in 1500 then a great deal of the marketing which had taken place in
England was rather localized with some longer distance flows going across the
kingdom in particular commodities,
cattle cloth and so forth.
By the early 17th century,
one gets a picture of a society which was ever more closely interconnected and
integrated by market dealings and commercial transactions.
This was in short are commercializing society and emergent market economy in
which the living and the daily economic dealings of a far larger proportion of
the population were shaped by the market.
Okay.
And finally,
it wasn't just becoming a more internally integrated commercial society.
It was one which was also linked increasingly to a larger world because the same
decades in the late 16th and early 17th centuries saw a transformation of,
of overseas trade from a pattern which had been very much based on short
distance traffic across the English Channel.
Few voyages down to other French and perhaps Spanish ports,
but predominantly concentrated on the narrow cs two one in which English
merchants were trading directly with far more diverse areas of the world.
They began doing so partly to look for new markets for English cloth,
partly also to get direct access to the source of much desired imports,
which had previously been obtained from the Netherlands.
They start trying to go direct to source looking for grain for wine,
for spices,
for luxury textiles from far a field.
That eight 16th century of course was the beginning of the great age of
exploratory voyages by English navigators,
divisors of Francis Drake,
Martin Frobisher and so forth.
But the really significant thing from the point of view of the economic
development of the period were those who undertake under took trading voyages to
establish new trades,
often with royal backing,
often through forming companies,
which would get a royal charter to conduct trade with somewhere with which
England had not previously traded direct.
So companies were founded with royal charters to trade to the Baltic in search
of the furs,
the grain of Poland,
the timber products of Scandinavia,
all of which had a place in England's growing economy.
Companies were founded to trade with Russia,
sailing north around Scandinavia to the port of Archangel.
They intended to proceed from there to get access to central Asian goods.
Um,
though that was an enterprise which didn't succeed,
but they established trade with Muscovy.
There was increasing trade direct with Spain,
but principally foot for wine and currents or which were extremely popular.
There was direct trade with Italy,
first of all.
And then with the Levant,
bringing in spices,
luxury,
textiles,
wine,
uh,
and other goods.
And finally,
once the Muscovy company had learned that it could not successfully reached the
east via Russia,
they imitated the Portuguese and went the other way around Africa to establish
the trade with east indies.
Um,
with the voyages of the east India Company chartered in 50 99 and voyaging for
the first time in 1,601
all of these trades,
once they had become established were consolidated and expanding in the course
of the early 17th century when they were joined by yet another area of activity,
the Atlantic traits by the 16th 30th.
We're already 300 English ships a year fishing of Newfoundland and bringing back
the fish to Europe where dried card was particularly popular in parts of
southern Europe and increasingly trade had been established with the colonies
established upon the American mainland after 1,607 in Virginia and then Mary
Land of course from the 16 twenty's onwards in the northeast and Caribbean
colonies,
notably Barbados being established in the same period.
Jamaica wasn't conquered til the 16th fifties.
Most of these colonies managed to get on their feet through establishing
plantation economies of course,
and they produce the goods which were increasingly imported into England and
then sold on to other customers.
Tobacco,
for example,
tobacco first being produced in large quantities from 1617 in Virginia,
the salvation of the colony,
60,000 pounds of tobacco will being imported into London already by 1622 by 1638
they were bringing in 2 million pounds of tobacco per annum.
And from,
yes,
we're very ungrateful to tobacco.
It had a major role,
uh,
and that was followed from the 1640s by another product about which were very
ungrateful sugar being produced in the West indies and export it for refining in
London.
So then we have a panorama of economic expansion.
Attempts to establish overall national income in this period are extremely
dodgy,
but a number of heroic economic historians have attempted to do it.
And you'll find the estimates there.
In section eight of your table,
it seems likely that between the 50s sixties and the 1590s national income has
risen by about 48% and it rose by a further 51% between the 50 nineties and 1640
over the 80 years as a whole,
something like 120% growth in national income.
In real terms,
if they're right about that,
and even if they're wrong by 20% it's still a lot if they right about that,
it helps to account for the fact that population growth was sustained as along
as it was and for the growing signs of prosperity,
which one finds throughout this period.
And yet,
despite those positive and optimistic signs,
as you'll see in the final table,
table nine,
the prices of basic food stuffs was still rising,
suggesting that despite increased output,
there was a continued imbalance between population and food resources.
The period also saw complaints of poverty and a Dick continuing decline in the
purchasing power of wages,
the declining real wages,
which you'll find in the final column of that table on the right.
So having looked at the panorama of economic expansion,
what we have to do next time is to look at how this growing national wealth was
actually distributed socially and how the trends of this period worked out in
terms of the actual life chances of particular social groups.
And I'll do that on Thursday.